[Applaudissements]
je me suis réveillé ce matin avec une
petite musique dans la tête
ça vous arrive peut-être à vous aussi 1c
petite musique là qui reviennent
régulièrement
c'est étonnant hein c'est musique
entêtante là qui nous envahissent
pour beaucoup d'entre nous certaines
chansons certaines musiques
constituent des marqueurs très très fort
de notre identité
et de notre autobiographie
je vais vous raconter
un fait divers tout à fait étonnant
le 7 août 2008 le daily telegraph publie
un article en fait qui n'est pas unique
mais qui est assez extraordinaire
à londres sam carter boulanger à la
retraite fait un infarctus et tombe dans
le coma
les médecins estimé qu'il avait des
chances de survie d'environ 30%
sa femme est présente et puis les
médecins lui dise vous savez
pour que la chambre ne soient pas
silencieuse ça serait bien de laisser la
radio allumée occasion
au bout de trois jours
sam se réveille en entendant la fameuse
chanson des rolling stones satisfaction
c'était le premier disque qu'il avait
achetée en 1965
quand il s'est réveillé il a déclaré
quand j'ai entendu cette musique je me
suis rappelé de ma jeunesse je me suis
rappelé de ma vitalité à cette époque
je pensais ah oui la vie ça vaut le coup
d'être vécue et ça marrant donné envie
de continuer de vivre
alors ce type d'exemple tout à fait
extraordinaire de réveil de coma à la
suite de l'écouté d'une musique et bien
on en a régulièrement de publier dans
nos médias et nos journaux et ça montre
quoi ça montre effectivement que la
musique est une madeleine puissante pour
aller chercher des souvenirs personnels
et faire émerger
des souvenirs parfois même enfouis
alors les relations entre mémoire et
musique bien c'est ce que j'étudie
depuis un peu plus de 20 ans dans mon
unité de recherche qui s'intéressent à
la mémoire humaine et à ces troubles je
suis chercheur en psychologie
plus spécifiquement en neuropsychologie
et donc l'objectif de mes recherches et
de mieux diagnostiquer et de mieux
prendre en charge des patients qui ont
des maladies du cerveau hélas la musique
se révèle extrêmement précieuse pour
d'une part mieux comprendre comment la
mémoire fonctionne dans notre cerveau
d'autre part pour savoir comment la
musique pourrait modifier notre cerveau
et aussi comment la musique pourrait
soigner guérir d'autres servent
par exemple
nous avons montré en neuro imagerie
cérébrale
que la mémoire de la musique et bien
active des régions du cerveau très très
large par rapport en fin de compte à la
mémoire du langage
le mémoire du langage utilise un réseau
très spécialisés
c'est une fonction extrêmement pointues
sur a prise
alors que la musique la mémoire musicale
et gain va envahir notre cerveau de
manière beaucoup plus large beaucoup
plus diffuse et ça c'est déjà un
avantage quand il y a une maladie du
cerveau et bien en fin de compte la
musique la mémoire musicale est beaucoup
plus résistantes à ces maladies
par ailleurs nous avons montré chez les
musiciens en regardant comparant le
cerveau des musiciens des gens qui
avaient fait au moins quinze vingt ans
d'études de musique et bien dans ce
cerveau des musiciens par rapport à des
non musiciens il y à des modifications
liées à leurs pratiques et notamment des
modifications dans les régions du
cerveau liées à la mémoire que non que
l'on appelle les hippocampes
plus il pratique la reine de la musique
de leurs instruments bien plus on va
trouver une densité de neurones une
augmentation de l'épaisseur corticale
dans ces régions
le cerveau change par la pratique de la
musique
enfin au niveau des patients alzheimer
eh bien on remarque que ces patients
malgré la maladie qui avance et bien
conserve une mémoire de la musique très
très très en fin de compte préserver
très présente vous avez sans doute vu
cette vidéo qui a fait le buzz de cette
ancienne ballerine atteinte d'une
maladie d'alzheimer un stade avancé a
qui ont fait écouter le lac des cygnes
et là d'un seul coup elle s'éveille et
elle retrouve la chorégraphie du lac des
cygnes qu'elle a dansé durant sa
jeunesse
plus étonnant encore avec la musique
nous avons pu démontrer que ces patients
alzheimer très amnésique pouvait encore
apprendre de nouvelles chansons des
chansons qu'ils ne connaissaient pas et
apprendre de nouveaux horaires alors
même qu'ils ne se souviennent pas
d'avoir appris quelque chose de nouveau
leur cerveau retient la musique alors
même que leur cerveau est très amnésique
on pensait que c'était impossible mais
la musique nous a permis de démontrer
que leur mémoire en fin de compte n'est
pas complètement abolie et que grâce à
la musique on peut arriver à la stimuler
alors qu'est ce que tout ça nous permet
de dire lac la musique
et la mémoire musicale
elle fonctionne beaucoup évidemment avec
les émotions et on peut penser que la
fonction principale de la musique c'est
de produire des émotions
alors ça c'est une idée tout à fait
familière de penser que
la musique et l'art pour nous produire
des émotions c'est tout à fait le cas la
plupart du temps
et que c'est assez universel et que l'on
va trouver effectivement ce caractère
universel des émotions musicales dans
toutes les sociétés humaines
mais il ya un premier constat à faire on
n'aime pas tous les règnes musique
on n'aime pas tous les mêmes musiques on
vient parfois de cultures différentes
et on peut se demander mais comment en
fait il pourrait y avoir quelque chose
d'universel derrière ses goûts musicaux
et ses styles culturel extrêmement
divers et bien là quand on regarde les
résultats des expériences de
neuroscience cognitive de ces dernières
années dans un contexte de laboratoire
si on fait écouter des musiques à des
participants et qu'on leur demande de
dire si les musiques sont joyeux ou
triste et bien on voit que leurs
réponses sont très homogène malgré leurs
différences culturelles
malgré leurs différences de sensibilité
à la musique
on va faire ses petites expériences vous
allez voir que en définitive on peut
être tout à fait majoritairement
d'accord sur le sens à donner à une
émotion musicale je vous faire écouter
des petits extraits de musique je pense
vous connaissez pas vraiment ils
viennent de musique de film et pour
chacun vous allez associés cette musique
à une de ces trois émotion joie
tristesse ou peur commence par le
premier extrait
[Musique]
si ça vous désabonner la patate
je suis un peu surpris un deuxième
extrait
[Musique]
si vous avez choisi la joie je vous
demanderai de venir après le tedx pour
me consulter
[Musique]
si vous avez peur à l'écouté de cette
musique c'est peut-être vous avez eu un
mauvais souvenir avec des clowns je ne
sais pas enfin
vous voyez que globalement on est assez
tous d'accord sur l'émotion à choisir à
catégoriser ça ne veut pas forcément
dire que vous avez pris du plaisir où
vous avez été en synchronicité avec ses
différentes émotions on va y revenir
si l'exercice que vous venez de faire eh
bien c'est ce qu'a proposé thomass
freaks
à une peuplade africaine qu'on appelle
les mafias qui sont des bergers des
bergers d'afrique équatoriale
il y a une dizaine d'années il a pu
rencontrer cemaf à vivre avec eux et en
fait ces bergers ils sont vraiment isolé
c'est très difficile de trouver en fait
des pubs des peuples à très isolée dans
le monde et c'est ma faille n'ont pas
l'électricité
est vraiment ils sont pas du tout exposé
à de la musique occidentale et quant aux
masses rice leur a proposé d'écouter des
musiques assez qui valentin très très
occidentale dans leur style eh bien ces
bergers ma femme ont réussi eux aussi
associés la bonne émotion au delà du
hasard de joie de tristesse ou de peur
en pointant les expressions faciales sur
les visages qu'il voyait en écoutant la
musique
c'était intéressant c'est dans cette
expérience c'est qu'en fait c'est la
joie qu'il a qui l'a mieux catégoriser
parler ma faim
pourquoi a en fait chez lui ma femme
quand on fait de la musique parce que
ils en font ils ont des pratiques
instrumentales je fais ma foi quand on
fait de la musique c'est dans les
moments joyeux de la vie sociale
et les malfrats ont eu un peu plus de
difficulté à catégoriser les musiques
triste parce que pour un ma femme ça pas
beaucoup de sens la musique triste parce
que la musique on ne la fait pas dans
les moments tristes de la vie
donc par cet exemple on voit bien qu'on
ne peut pas complètement ce
sans lever s'extraire en fin de compte
du contexte culturel dans laquelle la
musique se vit et vécu et se ressent
alors est-ce que hilliard malgré tout
quelque chose d'universel dans la
perception des émotions de la musique
quand nous percevons de la musique et
que prenons plaisir à l'écouté de la
musique nous allons faire travailler
activé ce fameux circuit de la
récompense
on appelait ce circuit dans le temps le
circuit du plaisir circuit de la
récompense ses terres qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui plus familièrement
quand on prend donc du plaisir à
l'écouté de la musique en actifs ce
circuit qui est un circuit très complexe
mais en fait ce circuit il n'est pas
spécifique au plaisir de la musique
puisqu'il s'active aussi pour le plaisir
culinaire
pour le plaisir lié au gain d'argent
lorsqu'on gagne à des jeux et aussi pour
le plaisir sexuel
donc d'une certaine manière il n'y
aurait pas un plaisir spécifique à la
musique un circuit du plaisir spécifique
à la musique
mais malgré tout on peut penser que le
plaisir musical s'appuie sur des réseaux
cérébraux qui sont très utiles pour la
survie l'adaptation de l'espèce
donc du coup traitement des émotions et
le plaisir musical il est universel ah
oui mais c'est peut-être pas si simple
on peut voir des patients qui à la suite
de lésions cérébrales vont avoir ce
qu'on appelle une année denis musicale
alors l'année données musicales c'est
quoi c'est que quand ils écoutent de la
musique eh bien ils n'éprouvent pas en
fin de compte de plaisir ils entendent
bien
mais bon ça ne leur fait rien alors on
peut comprendre on puisse avoir une
adreno ni à la suite d'une maladie du
cerveau par la déconnexion entre les
circuits de la perception et cie a pris
du plaisir mais en fait cette année
denis musicale elle existe aussi chez
les personnes qui n'ont aucune maladie
neurologique et ça c'est ce qui a été
découvert par les clips de robert adoré
à montréal c'est en faisant ces tâches
là que vous venez de faire de
catégorisation musicale ils se sont
aperçus qu'il y avait des sujets quand
on enregistrait lac telle accélération
cardiaque
la ventilation à la sudation et bien il
était capable de catégoriser
parfaitement les mélodies mais en
définitive il n'avait aucune réaction
émotionnelle alors qu'il y avait des
personnes qui en entendant de musique
joyeuse avec ces attaques avait cette
accélération cardiaque attendu donc dans
la population générale il y à des
personnes qui n'ont pas de maladies
neurologiques sont tout à fait normaux
mais qui ressemble peu de plaisir l
écoute de la musique on pourrait dire
qu'ils ont une fin d'année denis
musicale quasi non pathologique
mais alors ces personnes il n'éprouve
jamais plaisir à quoi que ce soit et
c'est là que l'équipe de robert da torre
en faisant passer ces personnes dans un
scanner en leur proposant notamment des
tâches de gain d'argent mais ils
s'aperçoivent en fait leur circuit du
plaisir il fonctionne bien
mais si ça fonctionne bien pour le gain
d'argent ça ne fonctionne pas
effectivement pour la musique n'a pas
été investi par eux en fait on peut
comprendre que ces personnes ils sont
capables de catégoriser des musiques
intellectuellement et comprennent ce que
c'est que la musique joyeux ou tristes
mais n'en éprouve pas d'émotions de se
synchronise pas d'un point de vue
émotionnel et ça en fait on peut faire
un parallèle avec ce qui se passe chez
certains enfants autistes qui sont
capables parfaitement d'apprendre que
quelqu'un est joyeux ou que quelqu'un
est triste par en fait par l'organe
l'orientation des traits faciaux
quelqu'un de joyeux quelqu'un de triste
mais n'éprouve jamais d'empathie
émotionnel
or justement on va parler d' empathie
émotionnel lié à la pratique de la
musique
on sait chez les enfants que la pratique
de la musique va leur permettre de
développer un certain nombre de
capacités intéressantes par rapport à
leur apprentissage scolaire
augmentation des capacités de mémoire
immédiate augmentation de capacité
d'attention de concentration etc mais il
ya des bénéfices aussi extrêmement
intéressant quand on pratique la musique
ensemble à plusieurs et ses bénéfices
sont le fait qu'il faut faire attention
à ce que ressent l'autre
attention à l'état mental de l'autre
attention effectivement au fait qu'il
soit bien synchronisés avec nous donc
faire de la musique ensemble chez les
enfants augmente développent leurs
capacités d'empathie
et ça a été étudiée assez récemment
d'un point de vue scientifique
avec des enfants autistes cinquante six
enfants répartis en deux groupes un
groupe avec interventions musicales un
groupe 100 interventions musicales
qui ont été suivis et le groupe avec
interventions musicales va augmenter ses
performances dans des tâches de
communication sociale et ça ça avait
déjà été montré un l'affluence de la
musique sur l'augmentation des capacités
de communication sociale chez les
enfants autistes mais ce qu'il ya en
plus en fait d'ancêtres dans ce travail
c'est qu'ils ont aussi montré que la
connectivité cérébrale de ses enfants
qui avait eu une intervention musicale
était modifiée et que leur cerveau se
rapprocher en termes de configuration se
rapprocher des enfants normaux typique
alors la musique
la musique elle est universelle
oui vous voyez que c'est en fait c'est
pas tout noir ou tout blanc oui la
musique s'appuie sur des compétences
relativement une des mes si elles ne
sont pas développées durant l'enfance
s'ils ne sont pas renforcés par des
expériences qui nous permettent de
renforcer notre plaisir des ducs et
notre plaisir et bien en définitive
on peut tout à fait ne pas investir la
musique comme étant un domaine qui nous
apporte une satisfaction
et peut-être qu'on va investir d'autres
domaines comme le sport
les jeux la lecture
à prendre le plaisir oui c'est une
réalité c'est à dire le plaisir c'est à
la fois quelque chose d'inné mais ça
s'éduque ça s'éduque est dû de ce fait
bien sûr que la musique produit des
effets intéressants pour les enfants qui
en retz qui le réalise pour leur
scolarité
ça c'est intéressant mais en plus ça va
leur permettre aussi de développer
leur sentiment
je dirais d'empathie et leur capacité à
vivre ensemble
et là on peut se dire bah c'est un peu
dommage quand même que l'éducation
artistique et notamment l'éducation
musicale en france
ne soit considérée que comme la cerise
sur le gâteau et ne soit pas le gâteau
en tout cas une partie plus importante
de ce cadeau à
leur goût du compte pourquoi la musique
c'est elle conservée dans toutes les
sociétés humaines est ce que c'est par
besoin effectivement satisfaction
émotionnelle
il ya un paradoxe sur le plaisir musical
parce que on va trouver de type de
comportement a priori opposés on va
écouter de la musique pour avoir un
plaisir personnel
solitaire et qui eux aussi on a le
plaisir d'être ensemble par la musique
écouter de la musique ensemble danser
ensemble
c'est vraiment une expérience de 5 rue
synchronisation sociale
nos corps à l'unisson notre coeur à
l'unisson notre cerveau à l'unisson et
les travaux de neuro imagerie cérébrale
montrent que c'est vrai nos cerveaux se
synchronise dans leurs activités
alors du coup la musique c'est un
antidépresseur culturel ben oui alors
pourquoi pas la prescrire
je pense qu'il est temps de prescrire la
musique car c'est un antidépresseur
culturel mais sans effets secondaires
merci
[Applaudissements]